。
各位同学好，欢迎来到咱们查理的编剧课啊。今天上第三十四节课。
这节课讲点啥呢？这节课想给大家讲一个比较重要比较实用的创作技巧，比较细节的创作技巧。
为啥呢？因为咱们最近啊发现一个问题啊。
就是很多同学听咱们的课。
从。
大面上。
掌握了一些技巧。
掌握了一些方法论，对吧？甚至于说呢看了咱们的课以后啊，他现在看电影啊就看的比以前顺了，能够发现电影里面很多问题，知道哎下一场要干什么了，对吧？
就是很多同学啊就感觉自己。
已经精通电影的商业片的套路或者结构了。但是自己写的时候呢，还是很拉胯。
还是很拉胯，特别是什么呢？特别是我最近看到很多同学交给我的作业。
交给了我作业。
空篇怎么说呢？
通篇流水账。
甚至有些同学啊。
他在大面上没有什么错误。
就从结构的角度来说啊，哎写的还真是那么回事，是一篇剧本。
是一个完整故事。
但是呢就是具体到每一个小事件，具体到每一个单场，具体到每一个信息包。
写的不精彩。
你还不精彩，这个问题就就就就就。
就比较麻烦了。第一不精彩这个问题啊很不具体。
是吧很不具体，你是说他不精彩，他他还要问哪里不精彩，对吧？大家不服嘞。
第二呢就是不精彩这个问题啊，既然不具体，这就很难解决。
这就很难解决，对吧？但是这是个通信的问题，通信的问题。所以说我们这节课就是来探讨一下，解决一下这个问题。
就是说你一个故事，你写出来以后，你感觉顺顺当当的。但是从读者的角度，从观众的角度，人家看起来觉得你这篇。
故事啊很寡淡。
不精彩。
对吧。
用我们在剧本探讨中经常说的一个词，说这通篇剧情顺片。
一下就知道你后面要发生是吗？
一下就知道你每件事情都走向了。
这个问题是这节课我们需要探讨。
这这种问题呢。
在新手当中啊是非常普遍的。
一般来说啊咱们归呃一般来说啊那归结于什么一些。
什么什么什么样的原因呢？说这个同学的戏感还没有培养起来。
或者是这个同学呢，他的基本功还是不够扎实。
他只是粗粗的学了一些。
方法对吧？他的基础的东西还没有打好。
但实际上啊我们不能笼统的这么去看问题，因为任何问题都是可以通过方法去解决的。你既然单场写的不精彩，单个事件不会构建，那么我们就可以对症下药，找到问题的解决方案，好吧。
举个例子说啊。
很多同学在写作的时候。
比如说写到这里。
知道。
这一场戏呢他有个什么什么样的诉求呢？比如说他有一个诉求，他想写。
我这场戏就想表现。
我这个主角的妈妈很爱他。
就我至少是有这个责任，有这个。
有这个任务，我有这个诉求，创作者有这个诉求，有这个信息包，对吧？
写一个妈妈很爱他。
很爱我们的主角。
但是呢那具体的是需要用画面来展现的呀。
对不对？
具体是要有画面来展现的呀。
这时候呢咱们同学就分成几种。
最最差的一种怎么写呢？就是和妈妈两个人坐在沙发上聊天，一个人织着毛衣，一个人吃着冰棍。然后妈妈跟他说，你知道吗？我有多爱你，然后就开始讲述我怎么爱你为你付出了多少，这是最最差的一种写法。我们要用台词推进剧情。
当然了，现在咱们大部分同学啊已经跳过这个阶段，已经越过这个阶段。
但是嘞大部分同学停留在一个什么阶段呢？就是妈妈拼命的给这个女儿做好吃的，或者给这个女儿做衣服。
织毛衣。
用这个来表现。
他对女儿的爱，他对孩子的爱，我们说这就叫顺片剧情。
这就叫顺片去行这样的。
单场也是不达标的，这样的事件设计，情节设计也是不达标的。
那么咱们这节课。
对于单场的情节设计。
给到大家一些方法和调理。好吧，这场就来研究一下单场，每个单场每个情节怎么设计。
所以你们现在学到这种程度了。
你们知道这场要干什么？
理论上，你们知道这场要干什么，但是具体情节。
还不会或者说还不够精彩。我们这节课来解决这个问题。
解决这个问题呢，我们传统来说有四个方法有四个方法。我们对于每一个单场啊，我们现在对于每一个单场。
每一个单场事件或者是叫我们每一个叫单场情节啊，每一个单场情节我们需要这个单场情节精彩。
我们传统来说有四个方法。
第一个方法。
当然是我们一直强调的。
每一个单场要有核心对抗。
核心对抗。
我们说这个事情往往是很多同学在这一步就做错了。
就他单场没有对抗啊，我经常说的是你单场没有声儿啊。
没有事儿啊，不要老坐那给我叨叨叨聊天，我要对抗我要可视化的事件。
对不对？我要可视化的对抗可视化的时间。很多同学在某个单场里面啊，在很多单场里面啊缺乏对抗。
缺乏对抗。
所以说这节课我们把它具体出来，核心对抗最起码给我找三种三种，三选一最起码找三种。
一种角色有没有目标？
就这场这个单场里面角色有没有目标，他有没有要做成的事儿，他有没有要得到的东西？
他得有个目标，有目标才能有对抗啊。你不能说我这场主角无欲无求。
无欲无求，无欲无求就坐坐着纯聊天，那就那就很容易出现没有对抗的情况。
好吧，所以说第一种你给我找有没有目标？第二种当然就是找有没有对手。
第三种，你们也了解了找有没有困境。我们经常说的目标对手困境。
每一个单场或者说每一个单情节。
或者是说每一个单个信息胞。
我们需要。
角色这场里面的主角，这场里面的角色他至少有这三个中的一个。
他要么有一个明确的想得到的东西，有个目标，要么这一场呢他要干掉谁，他要跟谁争。
他要拿下谁，对吧？或者呢就这常。
有困难了。
有困境了，你这样才能给我创造出。
这好。
对抗，我经常举例子啊，我说你如果这场戏仅仅是两个人聊天的戏，那我们这场就不要了。
完全可以放在别的地方聊呀。
全部是台词。
对吧我们台我们同学出现了很多初学者啊，初学者很多出现台词推动剧情的情况，就在那聊，你知道我这些年是怎么过的吗？对吧？你知道我为了你经历了什么吗？然后这边一听听他这么一说，好，那我原谅你了，你看用他们台词实现剧情转折。
就是最次的一种方法，对吧？但是你如果这段台词你又非要说。
那么你把安戴在安排在事件中说。
去做某个事情的时候说。
所以说既。
你的单场情节。
不够精彩。
第一个方法就是。
检查一下核心对抗，看看你是否没有设置核心对抗。
没有目标，没有对手，还是没有困境。
好吧，这是核心对抗。
然后第二个方法，我们讲单场的时候说过，每一个单场情节需要有一个转折。
需要有一个转折。
当然很多同学喜欢用反转啊，最后反转一下也可以。
也就是说剧情不要是一根直线。
在每个情节里面的剧情都不是一根直线，是需要包含一个转折的。
是需要包含一个我们可以称之为变化，有变化的。
当然了，因为变化很广。
所有的形态变化都所有的行动都会带来变化，对吧？形态转变都称之为变化。所以说你可以理解为每一个单场情节需要有转折。
然后第三。
第三。
我们说第二需要有一个转折，第三呢需要延续一个线索。
一个线索。
我说电影啊，它的故事啊，影视剧的故事啊，它是流畅的流动的。
每一个单场都是有用的。
不能让剧情停下来。所以有一件事情是延续下去的，我们通称为线索。
有一个线索是延续下去的。
就说他是多米诺骨牌啊。
这场发生的某个事情。
可以影响到下一场。
甚至让你预见到可以影响的下一场，你这样才有follow下去的欲望。
观众才有接着看玩播。
不撬侃不快进的欲网呀。
懂吗？就说这场带来的某个变化，你可预见了这下场要要要要用到。
要用到。
这是第三个。
第三个方向。
就是你的单场。
需要有具备的元素。
然后第4个。
一般给出的要求是什么嘞？
需要贴合人设。
切合人设。
这个事情啊我们很多同学也是会忽略的。
也是会忽略的。
就是写人设的时候啊，呜宣宣的啊，感觉自己可有本事了。我操人设写的他妈比正文都长。
对吧写一大篇。
写这个人啊如何如何那啥啥啥如何如何的性格，如何如何的怪。
如何如何的经历过什么事儿是吧？是人如何如何的有钱使，有有渊源，如何如何了不得。
结果呢。
结果呢写到正文转化为情节的时候，照样还是他妈在那织毛衣在那训他。
那你写了那些人设有啥用啊？
那你写的这些人设有啥用啊？
具体这个人他他是个什么多牛逼的人，还是多普通的人，还是一个多奇怪的人，还是个多常见的人，有什么区别呢？不照样跟他妈在那做毛衣，然后他妈跟他讲，你知道我对你有多好吗？对吧？你知道我小时候多疼你吗？
就还是写一样的情节。
还是写一样的情节。
导致大量的人食浪费。
就你设定了半天，你觉得一定会很精彩这个人设。但实际上你在故事当中啊完全没有体现。
大家看的是故事中发生的事情，通过这个事情对这个人产生感知，而你的人设啊全是描述，你最后没有。
没有实现。
没有实现，这就要求我们什么呢？这就要求我们每个单场选情节的时候。
我们要记得选的这个事情啊，要贴合这个人设。就像你来，我现在知道这一场我需要。
比如说男女主角吵架，我至少我知道需要他们来吵架，我需要展现他俩关系不好。
这是我的诉求。
我这一场需要展现我的男女主角，这一对男女朋友关系不好，这是我的诉求。
这是创作者的诉求。我根据我从老师那里学来的方法。
根据我对戏剧的感知，根据我对整个故事脉络的一个把控，我认为这里需要我的男女主角展现他们感情有裂缝。你看这种诉求我们在创作中经常有吧。
我们创作者经常会有这种类似这种诉求。
那么你在这里要展现你的男女你这一对男女朋友关系不好。
关系不好。
你咋展现呢？
你需要选一个事件吧，你需要设计一个情节吧。
那么你这时候涉计清间当然要跟着人设写了。
对不对啊？这个男女朋友，这个男方，他他是猪八戒，还是他是银角大王，还是他是柯真恶，那发生的事情他不一样的。
你不要千篇一律，对吧？我说那个最差的一种表现方式就是让两个人坐这儿互相埋怨。
我说这就是用台词推进剧情，用台词告诉大家，他俩关系不好。
同学说老老师，我不是用台词，我用打的俩人互相挠，你挠我一压，我扇你个大逼都。
你以为这就是用画面和动作展现剧情了吗？
其实也是非常顺皮的一种写法。你想展现男女朋友关系不好，然后就这样这样互脑打架，对吧？摔杯子砸砸桌子。
顺片。
明白吗？
所以说这是前四种方法。
我们一般来说。
解决一个剧情顺片，或者说叫解决一个单场情节枯燥。
乏味。
对吧无聊没有可看性，一般来说用的方法。
给。
寻找核心对抗。
这场有没有核心对抗没有删掉。
就这么简单，没有这场废戏啊。
对吧没有你看给我看什么。
第二呢，市场里面有没有转折？
有没有转折？
对吧需要有转折的呀，因为我们看一个东西不喜欢。
顺的东西啊。
我们看一个这个这个故事，我们说故事它是祈伏的艺术呀。
那我们每一坨情节，我们说一坨情节它要有转折的呀。
对不对？另外呢就是有没有延续线索。
上一场发生的事情，这一场有没有交代一下？
然后有没有对下一场进行一些展望和和期待，有没有引起我们的期待，那这才是流畅的故事嘛。
然后第四个方法，那就是你涉及这个情节，你要贴你的人设呀。
这样的人才会做出这样的事儿啊，才会这样做出这样的选择呀，否则你叭巴的弄那么多人事要干什么呢？
所以说单场情节枯燥往往是这四方面没做好。
但是我们之前课程上实际上是讲过这些内容。
对吧或者是在其他的课程上啊。
我好像。
在不同的场合，在直播的时候也讲过这些方法和内容，但是还是有很多同学做不好选择，还是有很多同学。
顺片。
所以这节课我们提出第五个方法。
第五个方法。
第五种。
补充这四种方法的，第五个小方法，好吧。
这个方法呢我们以前一般称之为正系反写。
叫正系反显。
但是我发现很多同学啊。
我以为他很容易理解，我跟他说了之后，我以为他很容易理解。
我没想到很多同学还是没有get到他的。
意思给得到他意思。那么这节课我们就把它模型化。
正系反写这件事情，模型化模型化，我们给他起个名字。
由于它是一个三角结构，好吧，便于大家记我们叫它，比如说叫查理小三角，好不好？
因为是咱们课上的。
创作方法我们称之为查理小三角。
查理撒像小三角。
我在讲正西反写的时候，我给大家举过一个例子，我给大家举过一个例子。
我说。
我们想要。
假设。
我们想要描写一个。
可怜的小孩。
描写一个可怜的小孩，对吧？可怜是我们的诉求。
可联是我们的诉求呀。
我们说一个小孩很可怜的。
没有妈妈。
然后呢，爸爸也赚不到什么钱。
对吧在工地上打工。
赚不到什么钱的，或者是爸爸是那个那个跑甩送，跑外卖，风里来雨里去，也没有时间陪他也赚不到什么钱。我们现在要描写这么一个可怜的小孩。
我们说传统的方式是什么呢？
我们的同学啊。
我们同学往往是会写什么？
往往同学写这个可怜小孩就真的去写他的可怜。
穿的破衣服。
人家有鞋子，他呢这个鞋子漏洞。
然后不好意思，对吧？那个脚上有个鞋鞋上露个洞，然后呢，别的小孩子那在那里有饭吃，他呢就是拿着凉馒头。
对吧然后呢，别的小孩呢跟爸爸妈妈这个下课要跟爸爸妈妈快乐去游乐场。我们这个小孩呢就没有没得去。
然後就跟爸爸。
说爸爸，我也要去游乐场。
老爸说。
我今天要送很多单的，我真的没有时间。
然后爸我要买冰淇淋，然后爸爸从口袋里掏出皱巴巴的5块钱，买冰淇淋还不够，是吧？现在中雪糕的很贵的好几十，我听说是吧？
这是不够的。
然后呢，我们同学往往就写这样的情节。
就以为很煽情很煽情，对吧？我说这个方法就比较不高级。
或者是说在戏剧里面。
诶，比较不精彩。
我们说这个这种形式，这种思考模式是哪来的？
我说就是正戏正邪了，只给。
对吧来我们想表达一个小孩可怜，那我们用什么？
来表达的可怜呢。
就是用穷。
然后哭。
但实际上用什么来表达可怜更好呢？
用什么来表达可怜更好呢？
用懂事儿，用坚强。
我们说这个小女孩。
在一面对有钱人小孩吃好东西。
他应对自如。
他不查。
他不吃，他就吃自己的带的冷饭。
面对有钱人，小孩儿去跟爸爸妈妈去游乐场，他不闹。
他就是帮妈妈帮爸爸打包那个快递，帮爸爸装货。
对吧别人小孩有什么快乐儿童餐吃，他没有他给他爸爸做饭。
他每天早晨给他爸爸把中饭做好。
7岁的小女孩每天早晨给他爸爸爸给他爸爸爸中午在外面送外卖的时候，需要吃的便当给他爸爸做好。
我们说我这么去写。
反而。
我们说写一个独立。
读咋写啊。
独立坚强。
你要写独立坚强这一面。
我们说反而更能。
映衬出。
这个家庭的可怜，我们常说嘛这个孩子懂事的。
懂事的让人可怜。
对吧这就是我们经常说的正息反析。我发现很多同学啊。
他没有完全掌握。那我们这节课就提出一个三角理论。
提出一个三角理论。比如说我们想表达这个小女孩的可怜单亲嘛，单亲可怜的绅世，我们不要用顺片句情写。
对吧我们先往独立监察写。
然后再走回来。
然后再回到可怜。
也就是说，我们先描写他独立坚强的一面，但是在某个点。
引入一个转折变化，引入一个转折变化，让大家破防。
在展现。
鼓励和坚强。
是假的。
独立和坚强都是假的。
哪有独立坚强的7岁的小女孩。
他总有让人破防的一下。
他真的内心他肯定也想吃冰淇淋的。
对不对啊？
他懂事，所以他没有要那个冰淇淋。
但是别人丢的冰淇淋的壳子，他忍不住想要去尝一尝的。
明白吗？所以说我们要描写这个先往这里走。
希要往独立坚强走。
然后给一个转折回到这里。
然后回到你最初想写的那个只给的状态。
当然了，点到为止不要过多停留，不要恋战，在这里不要留恋，点到为止一转，然后再达到你原本的目的。
也就是说，把你原本直线想给到的那个线性的顺撇的剧情给我换成一个三角形。
给我换成一个三角形。
以此类推，我们可以再想一想，再想一些例子啊。比如说你看啊比如说以这个穷为例，我们现在想表达我们的主角穷。
主角穷。
觉得很穷，没有钱。
我们以前咋写？
以前哪写写这个人付不起钱，写这个人抠门，写这个人斤斤计较，对不对？那就是我们以前的写法，直线来说是抠门。
抠门，我们现在不行。
我们引入一个。
第三角第三角呢我们就引入它的。
反义词。
第三讲我们引引引用我们引入的往往是我们以前直线剧情的反义词，空文的反义词是什么？
空梅的反义词是什么？
我们想描写一个人穷，我们先不要直接写它cam，我们先写它大方。
鲜谢他大装逼罚钱。
那个沈腾。
夏洛特反恼。
穿着鸡毛衣坐着那个什么什么车，忘了啊，是应该是总裁吧，是吧？总裁那个那个那个他小舅子还小叔子小舅子开了一个总裁。
然后那个。
装大化。
然后呢。
转折。
变化拆算大。
加大了。
没有钱的。
刚才举的那个例子。
我们说你这场戏。
你想写什么来着？
你想写你的男女主角，这个男女朋友啊或者这对夫妻啊。
夫妻关系不好。
我们说这是你的诉求。
对不对？
你想描写一对夫妻的感情不好，这是你的诉求。
直线矩形是什么？
没错。
好价。
你你用直线矩形写的时候，你就给我用吵架写，对不对？是不是用吵架写？
吵架的反义词是什么？
对于一对夫妻来说。
你看嘿那个我看云宽一笑，我就知道云宽已经想到了，是吧？
你给我写。
吵驾。
这就是直线矩形。
那你给我写这件事。
那写这件事情咋写呢？
他必须是假的呀。我们说他跟你看假大方，假独立，假坚强假这个。
就说明这个夫妻啊感情不好已经很久了。但是他们约定，比如说每个月10号。
必须完成一下。
所以两个人就在那，你写这场戏的时候啊，就写两个人在那例行公事，寡淡无味，互相应付，互相嫌弃，甚至互相都不看。
啊，然后呢完成这个。
寂静。
这个这个任务。
假，然后呢转折。
当中因为一个什么插头在吵起来。
在回归。
你的诉求。
再回归你的诉求。
明白吗？这才是。
我们说的珍惜凡现。
由于很多同学总是理解不了正反。
那我们用图形的方式。
给大家讲。
它就是个三角形。
是你原本顺撇的线性剧情引入一个反义词。
过去拐一下。
那么同理，那夫妻关系好嘞。
夫妻关系好。
一样。
夫妻关系好，我们本来要干啥？
本来要干啥？
本来要写他们甜蜜，对不对？
后者本来要写他们那那什么。
那我们干嘛？
先去吵架那里兜一圈嘛。
我们先去炒。
因为夫妻再好，关系再好的情侣，他也会吵架的呀。
只不过是人家吵架可能更容易化解，可能用更好的方式解决。
其实你想描写关系好。
完全也可以先去吵家那里兜一圈。
完全可以去兜一圈，然后再回到甜蜜，或者回到家玩。
然后再回来。
带回来。
这就是我说的。
小三角，你从这个角度去理解，从今天开始，我们不再用正西反写这个概念。有很多同学理解不了，我们就用查理小三角去理解。
你想表达什么？
啊，想表他。
啊，顺那你很自然的就想描写他抠门，买不起东西，付不起账嘛。
对不对？
够。
出去给我绕一圈。
这就是我们说的第五种方法，它也符合前四种，它跟前四种是匹配的。
我们可以看这个案例。
你们可以看几个案例。
范伟老师演的耳朵大有福，这场戏讲的啥呢？这场戏讲的是范伟老师这个角色啊从工厂下岗了。然后他老婆呢？
在这个住院，他老婆在住院。
瘫痪在床，等于呢他现在也没有钱了，他自己工商也没评上啊，没有钱。
很窘迫，但是这么一个情况，实际上就是讲穷啊，实际上就是讲穷啊。
那么他就是典型的先从大方那里绕了一圈。
我们来看一下这场戏。
组织上决定我留下，我要胡总组的决定啊。
你也留下了。是啊。
走吧，我送你回医院，不，我回头回医院，小白同志，让你留下，嗨，还怕没事做吧，走。
代表何书恒，1935年2月，从江西向福建转移途中，在长汀突围战斗中壮烈。
十一瞿求白1935年6月18日，在福建长兵罗汉岭。
陈毅红军长征后，他领导了三年艰苦卓绝的赣南敌后游击战争，是唯一没有参加长征的共和国元帅。
的同志。
哇哇，就是个成姑娘。
哎有大哥。
24小时挣钱，全天后充方便呢，你愁啥整？
我要有你的好男。
早睡再说，退了，真假的嗯。
光荣了。
对。
送礼袋一块一块的啊，开包大菜呗，不用，我这里啥都有啊。
微笑。
这铁路上退休金咱比地方多吧。
多少不说呀，关键是这人没了之后，还追加一年工资呢，要不说咋没法和你比呢。
这退了以后打算干点啥呀？
生活大楼整包宝健。
上公园耍剑去。
挺潇洒呀。
啤酒什么卖的好啊？
我也要来呀。
他不来，我就不喝酒了。
来点小食品哦，你多来点垃圾食品。
这时候喝酒啊。
就是新闻联播就98国内新闻合一瓶，国际新闻合一瓶，剩下两瓶重播时候回家都。
那你这酒喝着，这也太有意义了，不是便破拆散，而是为了革命大局呀。
那轮是因你们草鞋卖的咋样？用大前门好牌子了，毛主席要抽下净车毛主席凑这便宜，主席吃饭睡觉，咱俩干点啥的啊，哎你可以就这个长征，毛主席抽下大前门，俺小平同志没烟来管毛主觉来。
可欣从这高低尝上这我看过呀，，我咋没看着啊，那这发霉了呗，抽烟怕发圈吗？你好就这个咱抽的不是价钱，咱抽个信仰面酒烟一共多少钱？送金千里面1.1块嗯。
烟1块54瓶啤酒6.4多少钱？9块。
要多保重。
嗯。
钢把我也丢放个水杯。
啥玩意乱的，我是坏人。
大哥，你这么有心啊，怎么这么斤斤计较？
好啊，就是这场戏。
可以看出范伟老师这个。
惊为天人的演技啊，范伟老师确实是中国男演员演技天花板啊，演技天花板，因为它可以塑造的范围特别广。我们说好的演员啊，很多很多好演员虽然也很优秀，但是一直只能演一种角色，对吧？但是范伟老师确实是演什么像什么这一点我们。
绝对佩服啊绝对佩服，确实是眼什的相声，跨度非常之大跨度非常之大。然后这部电影呢。
范圆老师演的这个角色。
他现在处于一个经济窘迫的状态，很穷。
对吧，但是呢。
他没有写他的窘迫，他反着写，反而写了一个什么呢？反而写了，他就可以去一个小卖店装大方。
是吧在这摆阔是吧？给我来个这个给我来个那个哎，啤酒怎么卖的，烟怎么弄的？哎，我们铁路上退休，这咋的在那装大方。
装大方，我们看一下这场戏就是典型的。
哈利小三角。
正西反写，对吧？而且也全部符合这些要求。首先有没有核心对抗？
很有困境吧。
他穷呀，想表达他的困境，他穷，他买不起啦。
很多东西吃不起，买不起啦。
然后来也有对手，对吧？跟那个人在那。
跟那个那个网吧老板小卖部老板在那装，在那装有对抗，有明确对抗。因为最后就是人家揭穿他的嘛，人家把他拆穿了呀。
对不对？
我们说有转折吧，我们说这里必然带来转折呀，装大方必然装不下去呀。
是最后还是要回到假的呀，假大方呀。
装大方装不下去，被人拆穿了。
被人拆穿了。
然后我们说线索延续线索。
线索延续的非常明确。上一场戏，他去医院给他老婆送饭。
所以他老婆吃完饭剩的那个菜汤。
他用剩的菜汤下了一碗方便面，所以那个镜头是缩了那个鱼骨头。
那个饭盒是给他老婆送饭的上上一场戏的线索。
然后下一场戏呢，下一场戏是他要招待他的女婿。
招待他的女婿，他想问他女婿借点钱。
所以卖啤酒。
所以卖啤酒那个老板说的是对的。
那老板看他要买啤酒，不是说他吗？女婿要来啊，然后他还硬撑说她不来，我就不喝酒了。
那个啤酒就是下一场戏的线索。
对吧这就是我说的承上启下，因的啤酒是给女婿买的呀，要么女婿借钱呀，要招待人家要要要舔女婿了呀。
对吧经济条件不好，上一场接老婆吃剩的菜汤。
线索下一场呢买啤酒。
再加上那个老板点的那句话，遇示下一场要问女婿借钱了。
这就是我说的线索。
承上启下。
剧情是流动的呀。
看了这场想吃爱下场呀，吃的这串想下串啊，对不对？这才是剧情，这才是故事，这才是故事。然后嘞，贴不贴合人设。
打肿脸充胖子的。
这么一个角色。
坚信自己。
也比较坚信自己吧，就是自我感觉良好的老一代。
国企。
与员工对吧？总感觉自己是时代的弄潮儿。
实际上被师太抛弃了。
被时代抛弃了。
很符合他的性格，总感觉自己活在巅峰，在铁路上往铁路上，是不是总感觉自己在国企，实际上已经被时代无情的抛弃了。
非常贴合人生。所以你看这场戏就是我们说的典型的一场好戏，一场漂亮的戏。
一场符合规定的戏，一场津津有味值得咱磨的戏啊。
这场戏情你看我们单抠出来，你没看过这个电影也很好看嘛。
也很好看嘛，这就是我说的一个优秀的单场啊，单抠出来也能打。
单抠出来也能打。
好吧？
我们说这是范伟老师的一场戏，我们再来欣赏一场当幸福来敲门里面威尔史密斯的一场非常好的表演。当然，威尔史密斯前段时间在这个奥斯卡上删人了是吧做这个事情当然做的很不好啊，但是这个这个与我们学习无关。我们只看。
他在作品中的表现啊，我们只看他在作品中的表现。这一段呢讲的是。
当幸福来敲门里面。
威尔史密斯带着他的儿子两个人走投无路。
两个人走投无路，无家可归。
一个一个父亲带着一个儿子走投无路，无家可归，没有地方住的时候。
这么一场戏。
正常来说，这么一场戏。
走投无路的一场戏，我们会表达他的绝望，会变得表达他四处碰壁，对不对？
但是这么写不就又。
实现了吗？
不就又没有小三角了吗？
他怎么写的呢？
与走投无路绝望。
相反的意思是什么呢？
父子两个人做游戏。
父亲带着儿子做游戏，说我带给你冒险。我们现在要躲避怪物的追击。
躲在这里不能出去，咱们今天就躲在这里，不能出去了，不是没有地方住，我们是要躲在这里，因为外面有怪物。
用一场欢乐戏。
表达绝望和走投无路。
大家看一下。
是这。
现在。
有吃哪。
All we got to do is push this.
Button right here.
我不是。
ok。
我没。
关钱。
嗯，楼准备宣读书了。
You your eyesYou close your eyes I want to see.
跟我 push许 together。
去 eyes去 eyes。
Oh my goodness.
我open open open.
我 is it。
au don't these dinosaurs.
Look around, get all these dinosaurs.
你谁呀耶。
我 don't step in the fire. We're kid men.
Need thispi because there's no electricity and it's cold out here, okay.
my we.
，我要他卖了给干嘛干嘛。
You backHere it is, here's a cake Come on right here, here go go go.
Yeahthan so.
好，就是这么一场戏，非常短。
但是非常有力量非常有力量，符合我们的所有的标准。
典型的一个困境。
典型的一个关节。
没地方住了。
要解决这个问题啊解决这个问题。
然后呢。
当中有转折了。
假的那个游戏啊。
假的那个欢乐。
站不住的呀。
人家打扫卫生的人来砸门的时候，你看他绝望成什么样子啊。
你就是走投无路了，再回来。
再回来。
对吧这就是我们说的标准的。
三角。
三角结构。
好吧。
这节课呢就是给大家主要讲一下这个比较重要的知识点。
比较重要的知识点。
留一下这节课的作业。
创造一个小三角。
创造一个三角情节。
创造一个三角情节，先画出一个三角。
把你的关键词写出来，你想表现什么？然后。
怎么去哪去哪里？反义词呢里绕了一下，再回来再表现它。
写出一个标准的小三角。
先写一个三角公式。
然后根据这个公式给我写一段剧情。
这就是我们这节课的作业，分两部分啊，先写一个三角结构，三角公式，然后再把具体的这场戏给我写出来。
咱们的作业还是交在编剧课点CN上。好吧，咱们最近的作业啊都是交在编剧课点CN上。
这个作业啊这个作业的提交和批改针对的是全体自学班的同学啊，全体自学班的同学在这里再次跟大家强调一下。
我们坚持。
给大家讲公开课，坚持。
给大家布置作业，甚至坚持花时间给大家批改作业，还要找地方给大家交作业。
为的是什么呢？为的就是帮助，尽量帮助更多的同学。
学习编具知识。
实现。
创作梦想对吧？
但是在咱们前段时间啊在咱们前段时间由于。
由于什么呢？由于咱们有。
付费的编剧孵化营对吧？付费的编剧孵化营导致很多免费自学的同学呢。
产生了吸率波动。
有些波动呢还比较明显，甚至直接对吧？表达出来。
比较典型的就是想不到老师竟然还收费代班是吧？我不学了，我看错你了，我不学了。
然后呢，他就。
退出学习了退出学习了。
我我想对这样的同学或者是有这样想法的同学说一句。
不是我对你们说的话。
是尼采说过的一句话，尼采说过的一句话。
就说每个人啊。
都要写好自己的。
人生故事活在自己的剧本里。
你自己的故事。
不是不是你父母的续集，不是你儿女的全传。
也不是你朋友的番外篇。
是你自己的人生故事，你最应该重视的是你自己。
你要跟你自己。
和解和你自己。
做朋友。
你自己才是你人生剧本的主角。
人家别人做什么事情。
不要影响到你，甚至我做什么事情也不要影响到。
对不对？
我我开孵化营也好，对吧？我拍戏也好，我干嘛也好，跟你的学习没有关系。
你只是从我这里学点知识，把你自己的人生过好。
这是我想跟大家说的一句话啊。
当然了，大部分同学其实明白这个道理，对不对？大部分同学明白这个道理，学习是给你自己学的，你不学了。
并不能惩罚我。
并不能惩罚我，好吧。
那个。
所以说咱们全体自学班的同学。
有兴趣学的认真的做作业。好吧，认真的做作业。然后咱们会在直播课中选取一些做的比较。
典型的一些作业吧来进行批改和点评。
这节课就上到这儿，下节课再见。
嗯。